MARK MIRCHANDANI:
What's up, everyone?
Thanks for checking
out This Week
in Cloud, where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
You probably already know that
Google Docs is a great place
to collaborate, but now you can
use the flexibility of an API
to do even more.
Whether it's importing docs
from a content management system
or programmatically adding and
templatizing existing docs,
find the demos and code samples
that you need to get started,
and see examples of it in
action at the Docs API website.
What will you build?
Google boasts a high-quality
private global network
that you can use
to keep your cloud
applications running smoothly.
With the launch of Google
Cloud's Network Service Tiers,
you can now optimize
your workloads
for performance and cost.
Are you running a job where
every millisecond counts?
Use the Premium Tier to
minimize the number of hops.
But if you're running a more
cost-sensitive workload,
or you're not as concerned
with network speed,
save some cash by using
the Standard Tier.
Start customizing your
projects and workloads
by choosing your
network tiers today.
| course, if you want to
learn more about networking
and show off your
skills, Google has just
rolled out a new certification--
Cloud Network Engineer.
Check out this great blog post
from a solutions architect
who made the leap from
networking on prem
to the cloud.
Tom shares tips on how to
stay highly sought-after
in an ever-changing landscape.
So study up, and get certified.
If you're one of the millions
who already uses Box,
get ready to see
what happens when
you take advantage of the new
Google ML services integration.
Upload a batch of files,
and watch Google ML
do all the sorting
and tagging for you.
Want to see it for yourself?
Follow the code tutorial
we've linked to,
and have a fully functioning Box
integration running in minutes.
Do you or someone you know
have to deal with customers?
If so, you may know how
important customer lifetime
value is and the challenges
of trying to predict it.
We've got a great
solutions article
that explains how to model this
value with machine learning
and walks you through how
to implement and host it.
Get your hands on it, and
try it out for yourself.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.